we know that immune system protects our
body from all kind of harmful pathogens
and serves like a defense system for our
body but sometimes there are situations
that is faced by our immune system known
as hypersensitivity now hypersensitivity
is a overreacting situation of the
immune system now you can also think of
that our immune system is hypersensitive
definitely sensitivity is important for
any kind of physiological system to
protect our body but hypersensitivity
instead of being beneficial it's
detrimental
now the hypersensitivity could be of
different types out of that type 2
hypersensitivity is IgG mediated or anti
prevalently antibody mediated and it
involves complement fixation and
degradation of the cells by antibody
dependent cytotoxicity so both these are
the features of type 2 hypersensitivity
normally when our body encounters a
harmful bacteria then they are like
antibody producing plasma cells which
produce antibody against this bacteria
let's say on specific antigens on this
bacteria and the cells of our body which
has FC receptors which can recognize
these antibodies such as a macrophage
such as a neutrophil can bind to these
antibody on and which are like
decorating the bacteria and now they can
release chemicals which would destroy
the bacteria or the macrophage might
even engulf the bacteria and thereby
body get rid of these pathogen and
that's how the body fights back but this
antibody secretion could be also
detrimental under certain circumstances
instead of destroying a bacterial cell
or a pathogenic cell it can destroy your
own cells as well so let us take an live
example to understand this antibody
mediated type 2 hypersensitivity
reaction in details so one of the
greatest example of type 2
hypersensitivity reaction is mismatch
power transfusion so
it occurs and we know that like there
are like four blood group right blood
group a B a B and O and blood group a
has anti-b antibodies in the serum
whereas a antigen what would be is
reverse it has P antigen on the RBC
surface whereas an T a antibodies in the
serum blood group a B doesn't have any
kind of antibody in the serum but has
poured the antigens on its RBC surface
the blood group O doesn't have any kind
of antigens on the surface but it has
all the antibodies like NT n and to be
present in the serum now let's say let's
imagine a situation where a donor with
blood group P is donating blood to a
recipient with a blood group a so
clearly there is a mismatch and see what
happens after the mismatch so remember
that blood group a has a on D G antigen
on its surface whereas P antibody need
serum laruby has B antigen on its
surface whereas nt a in its serum now
one of the here is a blood cell which is
coming from the donor and on the donors
RBC there is B antigen present right
but this donor RBC is now circulating
inside a environment of the hosts blood
right and the host blood serum has a lot
of anti B antibody this anti-b
antibodies would bind to the B antigen
on the top of the donors RBC and
eventually what would happen is quite
detrimental first these antibody could
lead to complement fixation and the
complement proteins might decorate the
RBC surface and thereby creating a
membrane pore on these RBC as a result
these RBC would be lysed also it is
possible that this antibody decorate the
RBC surface and it is involved by a
antigen presenting cell or a macrophage
either the way there is lysis of the RBC
and this is also called reactive
hemolysis
and there is a situation especially new
ones known as
erythroblastosis fetalis which is a
consequence of type 2 hypersensitivity
now in this case what happens in short
the anti RH antibody
travels from the mother's blood to the
embryo or to the developing baby and
destroys it via several mechanism so
let's look at this process in a little
bit details so imagine we have an Rh
positive father and Rh negative mother
so the baby would be somewhere Rh
positive right now here the Rh negative
mother doesn't have any kind of antigen
on the surface of the blood cell now Rh
positive father has the antigens on R we
see membrane so the baby which would
also have Rh positive blood which which
would have P and pigeon on its surface
now since baby's circulatory system is
initially connected to the mother
circulatory system there could be blood
exchange but initially nothing happens
things go wrong when during the first
pregnancy when the baby is about to born
and the during perforation there is a
breakage of the umbilical cord and what
happens is there is some amount of
backflow of like fetal blood to the
maternal blood
now this fetal blood has the RBC's which
has D antigen in maternal blood you
don't have that so what happens is
inside the mother's body and P inside
the mother's body what happens is and TB
antibodies are produced
now even though in the first pregnancy
the antibodies are produced by that time
birth has happened nothing happens to
the baby now eventually there are P
cells the baby is born normally the
first pregnancy
there are plasma cells which secrets IgM
against this D antigen is produced also
there are some memory b-cells are
produced which can litter secrete IgG
now since this I G M which is specific
to the antigen group B is pretty big
because IgM rpenter mini so it's very
hard for them to cross the placenta so
this is not a harm during the second
pregnancy what is harmful is the IgG
antibodies because it can cross the
placenta and it can go inside the baby's
bloodstream and what it can do is lice
its RBC and as a lysis of the RBC
hemoglobins are out and now there is
like huge amount of hemolysis which
leads to a problem in the infant first
of all it is huge amount of blood loss
most of the cases the infant don't
survive that and that's why there is
death at these during the second
pregnancy but nowadays nobody really
dies and there are ways to prevent this
kind of hypersensitive reaction and the
principle is fairly simple
imagine a jet plane now when it is
chased by an Mesa missile one of the
options is jet plane can do is release
flares and which would destroy the
missile in the mid-air right and the air
airplane is safe so similar kind of
strategy can be adopted to save these
babies from hemolysis so we know that
the baby's body has B antigen and there
would be different kind of antibodies
produced again against it but if you
give a sequestering molecule which would
sequester these antibodies which are
produced in the mother's body then it
won't be harmful anymore and thereby the
baby would survive and there were you
can get rid of the harmful effect of
type 2 hypersensitivity I'm sorry here
it's written as B antibody or B antigen
it actually I meant T antigen which is
important for Rh blood groups so I hope
you enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you